with victory in focus lioness euphoria
is spreading
for bristol city and its captain a
former england player this is not just
about women bringing football home it's
not just a massive game for women's
football it's a massive game for england
it doesn't matter if it's men or women
then men have never won the european
championships
the women could do that on sunday so
yeah i mean it'll be
great to have some banter with the lads
here about it but i think it's going to
be amazing not just for england women
but for england in general and can you
hold it over them if they if you do yeah
germany training ahead of sunday have
taken the title eight times last meeting
england in a women's euro final in 2009
to a crowd of fifteen thousand this time
is to a sold out wembley of nearly
ninety thousand really wanted to inspire
the nation and we wanted to do everyone
proud our families our friends we wanted
to grow more opportunities for young
girls young boys i wanted to grow more
opportunities for women that want to
work in football i wanted to get the
sport the respect that it deserves and
if you ask me i think we've ticked all
them boxes
a 19 match unbeaten run england has
taken the women's sport from the back to
the front pages
it's a pivotal moment for women's
football not just for the elite game but
for leagues below the wsl like bristol
city more prestige more euphoria means
more crowds and more investment
hopefully transforming the game for
players like jasmine bull with no more
part-time jobs to be able to dedicate
yourself massively to football i think
that will also change the performance
for women's footballers because you're
ultimately focused as football and not
having to juggle part-time work football
and i think that will also increase
increase the performance of the game
the road to wembley has been long but on
home soil a defining moment is now in
reach adele robinson sky news